hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to sister location custom
night now this isn't just an addition to
the game this is completely new content
and point being there's new characters
here frankly I don't know who the hell
yendo is I don't know where yendo came
from I don't even know if Eno was in the
original game but yendo is here and
yendo has weird effects kind of like
golden freddy he'll appear if you drop
your monitor and you got to open your
monitor again to make him go away and I
bet if you don't it kills you
and there's Bonnett who is not bonbon
the blue Bonnie that was on fun times
Freddy's hand that is bonbon this is
bonnet on it will streak through your
office and you got a pooper on the nose
before she goes away or else I'm
assuming you die then this Biddy Bob
electro Bob and then there's a little
bit who appears on the monitors in your
office and you gotta type out lol on
your keyboard to make her go away
him/her I don't know the computer
program I guess any other mini Riina's
and by Laura and fund I'm Freddy it's
just [ __ ] bonkers what custom a DS
gonna be in this just golden freddy mode
there's more modes in here that have
different assortments and various levels
of difficulty so it starts out with
angry ballet goes to Freddy and Co
funtime frenzy dolls attack girls night
weirdos top shelf bottom shelf cupcake
challenge golden Freddy and assortment
levels of hardness this being the most
20th of 20 modes so if you guys are
ready I'm not gonna start with you know
what actually [ __ ] I'm gonna start
with golden Freddy mode 20 20 20 and
just to see what the [ __ ] I'm getting
myself into because if I'm anything I am
and with red hair and that's what I am
so vent shock left or monitor right door
I have never [ __ ] played this in my
goddamn life here we [ __ ] go I must
start off with the top and then work my
way back up from there cuz holy [ __ ] now
what the [ __ ] was that huh lol haha
hello
oh Jesus ain't good what's happening Oh
what the [ __ ]
stop that hey hey stop that stop it
Jesus oh hi hello how are you doing oh
this seems lessen hi oh jeez oh jeez
it's probably not fair for me to just
turn off all the care my my doors waste
on the power oh I didn't know what the
[ __ ] did I do
Oh [ __ ] know oh [ __ ] is anybody gonna
be able to do that how the [ __ ] would
anybody be able to do that how in the
[ __ ] would anybody be able to do that I
don't know but eventually I'm gonna do
that Jesus I don't have time to do that
not now anyway so what I'm gonna do
there's so many new mechanics here I
don't have any knowledge to approach
them so what I'm gonna do because this
is completely new content new content
that I have never explored before I'm
gonna go through these other custom
nights all of these
and try to learn as I go along piecemeal
style I will stir with Dancy pants you
know I feel it's kind of fair I was
rather insulting her and frankly she was
the only one that was not on my side
during this whole ordeal so I'm gonna
start with her I'm only gonna do very
hard by the way I'm not gonna do easy
why would I do easy I'm gonna go very
hard so Laura will approach from either
the west or the east I got to listen for
her music to gum louder then shut the
appropriate door min Irina will appear
at random to begin draining your oxygen
supply and eventually causing a blackout
administer a controlled shock to
deactivate them that's what I did when I
saw them on the camera and then the mini
Riina's will appear in block your view
that doesn't seem so bad I think I can
handle that as long as I got a control
on Bao also it's pretty cool than in the
in the camera now there's a bit of
mobility here
Oh Lu hi hey no no it's not that
hi [ __ ] [ __ ] you giggle at me you oh
uh are you gonna be there forever now oh
boy stop it hi
oh Jesus okay well I
[Music]
okay all right then hey [ __ ] oh okay
all right then this is that's actually
really cool because exactly like how it
was stopped yeah babe it's exactly how
it was when you were crawling through a
room okay so that's probably the noise
when it's really close so I gotta wait
for her to go away good oh I got time I
got see the limit of what really close
is stop because she dances around why go
away
goddamn it I can't okay so that right
there that's really close cuz that feels
like it's in my ear okay so I need to
use way less power
I'm doing terribly stop laughing trying
to listen trying to listen why another
one way I don't need you [ __ ] to say
I've got eyes for days [ __ ] stop
another [ __ ] one [ __ ] you alright
well Laura might be gone which would be
proven to be good for me I'm not gonna
put down my [ __ ] visor yet [ __ ]
I can do this blind can you stop clap me
little bastard luckily now there's a
button to press the camera which we've
never had before I can press s to bring
up the camera which is gonna make this
so much faster I can dig it
I can dig it this is okay stop so long
as they don't get more than five on my
screen I should be okay man if I got ten
things to listen to all at the same time
and watch and observe and these fuckos
getting in the way of my face it's not
gonna be good for the old where's my
berries I'm on it
it is gonna be silent now oh yeah ah see
okay I almost had you I almost had you
almost had it on my first try but I
didn't know what I was gonna do because
I didn't know what I'm [ __ ] doing hey
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
alright let's try that again very hard
go back into it huh brewski I can do
this I can do this easy I can clear all
these fuckos I am not yet the king but I
will be the king one more I can survive
with five on my face I know that now so
I don't mind you being there I'm okay
with you being there you don't bother me
I'm gonna know it through sheer muscle
memory alone ah daya got ya you thought
you could snook turns out you could not
stop moving cool alright we're good
we're good
Hong kis nose here still back
oh shut down for a nap did ye well too
[ __ ] bad I'm still here oh [ __ ]
you're over there
already then you're a giggly bitching
Jim hi welcome to the party you don't
need to be there in my face but you know
it's kind of nice to see you up close
for once I just like the feeling of
being held by all you little [ __ ] oh
I can't hit the doors with the buttons -
oh my god that's amazing
then I don't need to see it all I guess
I guess if there were other things
happening though see that but I can
control the doors with the buttons
that's really convenient then I actually
don't need to move here but I'm gonna
train myself to click anyway because I
know for future things I'm gonna need to
click Liberty floppity flibbidee flew
huh
haha got your number now Oh
moving moving moving keen ears oh
there's the last one about damn time
yeah that's it that's the stuff okay I
think I got it now
I'm gonna line yep definitely okay I'm
using the buttons now but I should be
able to make it a 6:00 a.m. no problemo
please I've only got a few percent power
oh yes I'm the best and I'm back in the
saddle again
No okay I did it I did it I [ __ ] did
it alright so what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna here that purple guy that's the
only thing that I can assume about that
she's wearing a purple shirt and his
mouth is very weird so I'm assuming I'm
assuming now is purple guy walking down
the street and everybody assuming it was
purple guy so I'm guessing he hid very
well so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna
check out Freddy & Co because Freddy &
Co is an entirely new environment I'm
not gonna be able to beat in this one I
don't think because there's some new
mechanics here that I'm not used to that
I probably couldn't be able to handle
very well but okay [ __ ] off funtime
Freddy what he's gonna do is he's gonna
command bonbon to attack so I need to
shut that door
depending on where he is so I need to
check the cameras yendo just appears on
after I drop the monitor
funtime foxy he's in funtime Cove he's
like foxy and then Barnett runs across
screen and something so I'm gonna pay
attention to that okay but this is gonna
require quite a bit of power actually so
I'm assuming that I got to pay attention
to pool okay suit ah that was from 500
yeah
okay alrighty then
so okay okay wait
yes Oh Thunder Bucky already okay hey
well with your booboo okay what I don't
know what the [ __ ] is happening here I
am NOT okay
[ __ ] [ __ ] does that mean you're gonna
attack oh that's the line okay so I just
need to listen to you and pay attention
to
haha okay fine [ __ ] you Jesus and scary
as hell okay so I know one right
wait but [ __ ] you wait where's Cole [ __ ]
where's lucky my [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh hi foxy oh hey [ __ ] is that some Ice
Age
oh hi okay yeah what okay he's on the
right side I'm in a little gal now
no well that was terrible
okay so but I was starting to learn
that's an important feature
okay so custom night looks to be an
onslaught of evil like the likes of
which you've never seen cuz that's not
even everybody on 20 and that's very
hard on Freddie and Co I would have to
do all of that for more and more and
more and more and more and more and more
and more and more until you get to
golden freddie until everybody is that
20 and I don't even know if that's
possible like how do you have enough
power to be able to do that you would
have to look at foxy look at the other
camera for the ballerinas that are
trying to drain your power you'd have to
knock down yendo beyond the ready for
that you'd have to be ready to click
bonnet type lol I haven't even faced the
Biddy Babs I don't know but it's a
challenge it's a goddamn challenge but
I'm up to it so but I'm not gonna be
able to get to it soon it's gonna take a
few episodes so good news there's a few
more episodes of sister location waiting
for you bad news I don't know if I can
do it but I believe in myself that's by
laying a foundation baby so anyway that
was the beginning of custom night
there's much more to come so thank you
everybody so much for watching let me
know what you thought down in the
comments below and remember this DLC is
free if you have the game you can play
all this for yourself so thanks again
and as always I will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]